the now comes the leader of the
opposition
thank you Mr Speaker this week we will
remember the Six Million Jews murdered
in the Holocaust and all those scarred
by genocide since as we Mark Holocaust
Memorial Day we must all commit across
this house to defeat Prejudice and
hatred wherever we may find it to work
for a better future we must find light
in the darkness could also join the
prime minister in wishing everyone a
happy Burns night
Mr Speaker Zara Alina was walking home
from a night out with her friends when
she was savagely attacked assaulted and
beaten to death
Zara was a brilliant young woman a
trainee lawyer with a bright future
her killer is a violent racist
woman-hating Thug not fit to walk the
same streets
but that's precisely the problem
he was free to walk the same streets
the inspectorate report into her case
says that opportunities were missed by
the probation service that could have
prevented this attack and saved her life
does the Prime Minister accept those
findings
Mr Speaker this was a truly terrible
crime
and as the Chief Inspector has found the
failings in this case and indeed others
were serious and indeed unacceptable
in both of the cases that are in the
public domain these these failures can
be traced to failings in the initial
risk assessment and that's why immediate
steps are being taken to address the
serious issues raised
okay estaba
I'm glad he accepts those findings
the report also says that Staffing
vacancies and excessive workloads
contributed to those fatal failures and
it makes absolutely clear this was not a
one-off
as the report says these are systemic
issues in the probation service
they're clearly ministerial
responsibilities does the Prime Minister
accept those findings as well
prime minister Mr Speaker let me outline
for The Honorable gentleman exactly what
steps we are taking and that's to
include
and that's to ensure that mandatory
training is to improve risk assessments
is being put in place it's mandating
checks with the police and Children's
Services before a probation officer can
recommend to the court that a convicted
offender be given electronically
monitored offense and implementing new
processes to guarantee the Swift recall
of offenders and the action we are
taking is already making a difference as
for example we see in the reduction of
the number of electronically monitored
curfews being given by the courts
estaba
Mr Speaker it was barking dagenham and
havering that tragically and fatally let
Zara down
but across the country Probation
Services are failing
after a botched then reversed
privatization after a decade of under
investment it's yet another vital Public
Service on its knees after 13 years of
Tory government
I spoke to Zara's family this morning
it's hard to convey to this house the
agony that they've been through
they say that the government has blood
on their hands over these failings
he's accepted the findings of the report
does he also accept what Zara's family
say
prime minister well Mr Speaker my heart
of course goes out to Zara's family he
mentioned accountability the Probation
Services has taken action where failings
have been found and where that has been
appropriate and with regard to the
overall service because of the extra
investment we're putting in there's now
155 million pounds a year it's being put
into the probation service so that we
can deliver better supervision of
offenders there's also been an increase
in the number of senior probation
officers but one of the other things we
must remember Mr Speaker if we do want
to increase the safety of women and
girls out on our streets that we need
tough sentencing and that's why this
government passed the police crime and
sentencing act which The Honorable
gentleman opposite and his party opposed
[Applause]
[Music]
in light of the case of Zara I really
don't think the Prime Minister should be
boasting about the protection that he's
putting in place for women and I'm not
going to take lectures from him about
that
does the Prime Minister agree
that any politician who seeks to avoid
the taxes they owe in this country is
not fit to be in charge of taxpayer
money
yeah
well Mr Speaker I'm pleased to make my
position on this matter completely clear
to the house
the issues
the issues in question occurred before I
was prime minister
appointment with regard to the
appointment of the minister without
portfolio the usual appointments process
was followed no issues no issues were
raised with me when he was appointed to
his current role and since I commented
on this matter last week more
information has come forward
and that is why I have asked the
independent advisor to look into the
matter now I obviously can't pre-judge
the outcome of that but it is right but
it is right that we fully investigate
this matter and establish all the facts
[Music]
Mr Speaker
he avoided the question I think any
anybody watching would think it's fairly
obvious that someone who seeks to avoid
tax can't also be in charge of tax yeah
for some reason the Prime Minister can't
bring himself to say that or even
acknowledge the question now last week
the Prime Minister told this house that
the chair of the Tory party had
addressed his tax Affairs in full and
there was nothing to add
this week after days of public pressure
the Prime Minister now says there are
serious questions to answer
what changed
prime minister
I know I know he reads from these
prepared sheets but he should listen to
what I actually said
[Applause]
since I commented on this matter last
week more information including a
statement
including a statement by the minister
without portfolio has entered the public
domain which is why it's right that we
do establish the facts and
he take a step back let me take a step
back now of course of course of course
the politically expedient thing to do
would be for me would be for me to have
said that this matter must have been
resolved by Wednesday at noon
but I believe in proper due process
[Applause]
the independent advisor is doing his job
but the opposition can't have it both
ways
the shadow leader is also his party
chair both
urged me and the government to appoint
an independent adviser and now he
objects to that independent advisor
doing their job it's it's simple
political opportunism and everyone can
see through it
[Music]
we all know why the Prime Minister was
reluctant to ask his party chair
questions about family finances and tax
avoidance
laughs
but but he's
[Applause]
he's failure
his failure to sack him when the whole
country could see what's going on shows
how hopelessly weak he is
prime minister overseeing chaos
overwhelmed at every turn
he can't say when ambulances will get to
heart attack victims again he can't say
when the prison system will keep streets
safe again
you can't even deal with tax avoiders in
his own cabinet
is he starting to wonder if this job is
just too big for him
Mr Speaker
the difference between him and me is
that I stand by my values and my
principles even when it is difficult
when I disagree fundamentally with the
previous prime minister I resigned from
the government
but before but for four but for four
long years he sat next to the member for
Islington North
When Auntie anti-Semitism ran right when
his predecessor sided with our opponents
the that's what's weak Mr Speaker he has
no principles and just Petty policy